[Music]
from the gates of his Florida Resort the
former president's motorcade emerging to
make history
this is an extraordinary moment for
America being no doubt about that a
president's long journey from his
Seaside Mansion to a courtroom dock
[Applause]
and his supporters were
but in the numbers he'd hoped for well
his son Eric filming from the Convoy was
spinning at his father's way
[Music]
unbelievable support for Miles he
tweeted
the only Glimpse here of the former
president on the tarmac in Palm Beach
and as he flew his legal team with a new
attorney now among them were putting
together their defense against charges
the details of which they and we do not
yet know
a thousand miles north on New York
City's Fifth Avenue in the shadow of
Trump Tower the homecoming his
supporters had promised was well thin
though they argued otherwise
no I'm not the only one the truth is
that they were outnumbered by police and
by the world's media for America's
deeply partisan cable news this is as
much about ratings as it is about
telling their interpretation at this
moment in American history from his fans
here a pledge that there will be no
trouble this is about supporting a
president wronged a victim of what they
say is a politicized Judiciary and we
know there's not going to be any
violence
[Music]
two blocks to the North in Central Park
beyond the circus a real world view from
three siblings their reflection of this
latest chapter in the Trump story I
think there'll be other more serious
charges prior to the election
between January 6 and then the Georgia
stuff the legal system moves so slowly
you know I mean because it's that's set
up that way and he'll use that to his
advantage of course he will yeah
everything's a money money raising
opportunity for him you know so we kind
of
I don't think he won't mind this that
much maybe he's hoping for a perp walk I
don't know of course here you hardly get
a representative snapshot of opinion New
York may be Trump's home but it's not
where his support is
he arrived in New York his legal team
was engaged in last-minute arguments
with the court protesting against the
prospect of cameras inside
and then on Fifth Avenue there he was
and so of all the scandals surrounding
Donald Trump in the end it was this that
forced him to court the story of a
president a porn star and a transaction
legal or not
in the day ahead we'll find out the
details and the reaction Across the
Nation stirred and divided Mark Stone
Sky News in Manhattan